et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Olivier marlès bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous députés d'Eure-et-Loir
président du groupe les républicains à
l'Assemblée nationale on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Julien Lecuyer de la
Voix du Nord bonjour Julien bonjour
Oriane bonjour monsieur et on va
évidemment commencer en parlant de
l'intervention d'Emmanuel Macron hier à
13h qu'avez-vous pensé Olivier Marleix
de cette intervention et des propos du
chef de l'État
je trouvais comment dire un peu à côté
de peu à côté de la plaque c'est
étonnant le principal message qu'on en
retient c'est je continue président qui
semble ne pas totalement mesurer que
même l'état de de de colère même si
l'employé le mot ce qui était un progrès
quand même par rapport à son message sur
la foule la veille mais voilà président
qui ne change rien donc c'est quand même
un peu inquiétant sur sur la suite
pour lui quand même qui était de tenter
de au moins de renouer le dialogue avec
les partenaires sociaux cette réforme
elle paye un ce manque de dialogue
depuis de depuis six ans quoi pas
simplement dans les deux mois de d'un
préparation mais dans les de depuis 6
ans après mépris des partenaires sociaux
et il a fait tout le contraire enfin les
propos qu'il a eu sur sur des syndicats
réformistes comme la comme la CFDT sont
pas je pense vraiment vraiment déplacé
c'est le retour de l'hyper président
selon vous
rien n'a changé rien n'a changé c'est un
peu le c'est un peu le problème je pense
que pour sortir de cette crise
avec le président change durablement et
il n'en prend pas le chemin mais est-ce
que il a eu la alors il a eu la denture
contre les grands groupes et il a fait
il a il a parlé de cynisme de certains
cette idée de contribution
exceptionnelle pour permettre aux
salariés de ces grandes entreprises
d'avoir une meilleure rémunération c'est
un signe vers la gauche c'est un signe
qui vous interpelle oui c'est la preuve
là encore qu'on a appris dans la
République qui manque un peu de
conviction essentielle ils ont combattu
l'idée de taxation sur les super profits
à un moment où elle était dans le dans
le débat au lieu de dire rapidement oui
un problème sur la sur le partage de la
valeur dans notre pays et puis pour
finalement le ramener par un détour avec
un avec un mécanisme
qui est en réalité aurait une portée
extrêmement limité puisqu'il s'agit de
de d'encadrer les pratiques qui sont
effectivement à peu près les
mathématiques de rachat d'action quoi
mais ça ne vise que ça ça risque les
entreprises qui utilisent leur super
profit pour pour acheter de l'action ce
qui est un phénomène assez étrange quand
même ça ressemble à date destruction de
valeur dans l'entreprise ça hérite
beaucoup c'est un sujet dont on parle
beaucoup le président de la CGCF
François bride mais bon donc en réalité
ça ne changera pas grand chose et à côté
de la plaque il y a un vrai sujet dans
notre pays sur sur les salaires c'est
c'est pas le problème c'est pas que les
entreprises fassent des dividendes
il a parlé quand même de négociation à
relancer avec dans les branches on a un
peu l'impression que le Président il est
en permanence un peu dans l'air du temps
essayer de capter des mots mais que
derrière il y a pas de il y a pas de
vrai conviction il y a pas de
est capable de regarder c'est le drame
de cette salle de cette de la de
l'incompréhension par les Français c'est
très fort me souvenez-vous de ce qu'il
en disait lui-même il y a il y a trois
ans reculé là je la retraite 104 ans il
faisait ça en riant que c'était
impossible etc comment voulez-vous que
les Français admettent aujourd'hui cette
réforme alors que que lui-même la la
conspuait il y a 3 ans c'est c'est
à convaincre les Français de la
nécessité de cette réforme mais en même
temps il assume il dit ça ne me fait pas
plaisir mais je souhaite qu'elle entre
en vigueur avant la même chose pour
accompagner le changement il a eu raison
je pense qu'il a rien réglé pour
accompagner le changement il faut avoir
des convictions solides et il faut être
capable de d'expliquer aux gens pourquoi
on fait lui n'a pas de conviction sur la
réforme de retraite il a présenté il y a
4 ans une réforme qui était tout autre
qui cassait la sécurité sociale et
d'ailleurs qu'on a à l'époque
vigoureusement combattu considérant que
c'était plutôt une réforme sur les
appels paramètres qu'il fallait faire
bon mais c'est pas là c'est c'est pas
totalement la sienne on le voit bien il
est pas très à l'aise avec et donc est
incapable de de convaincre la politique
ça suppose je pense de l'engagement
d'abord de la sincérité on n'a pas on
n'a pas les deux et l'envie de se faire
comprendre et de parler français est-ce
qu'il a eu raison de renouveler sa
confiance envers Elisabeth borne
c'est vraiment c'est sa responsabilité
enfin c'est son choix dans la République
après ce qui paraît après je t'y paraît
49-3 c'était pas une surprise soyons
soyons très clairs depuis le début il y
avait une très forte probabilité que le
texte soit adopté par 49,3 puisqu'il y a
pas de majorité absolue à l'Assemblée
nationale tout est tout est plus
compliqué c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
choisi c'est même pour ça la dernière
minute comptait sur l'appui des
républicains
PLFSS présents sociales pour utiliser un
49-3
et le fait que la première ministre a
été missionné pour tenter d'élargir la
majorité essayer de trouver à droite et
à gauche alors je cite c'est des des
femmes et des hommes de bonne volonté
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est encore
faisable
écoutez non je suis à la méthode du du
débauchage je pense que elle est
totalement totalement éculée
c'est pas possible alors c'est ce qui va
rester gouvernement pour du très
clairement que que ce choix c'était non
pour nous on l'a dit on l'a dit au
premier jour de cette de cette
législature
un peu différent il a dit s'adresser au
parlementaire qui ont soutenu la réforme
c'est à dire vous notamment il a dit il
vous a un peu tondu la main finalement
il a dit il y aura pas de de coalition
on a compris les LR ne sont pas compris
une coalition mais il va voir il dit
mais il y aura des individualités est-ce
que vous vous la saisissez
si c'est une encore le petit jeu de
débauchage je pense que ça n'a aucun
intérêt que ce n'est évidemment pas à la
hauteur du du président de la République
à fracturer le pays il a eu comme jeu
politique depuis 6 ans maintenant de
pousser la gauche dans les bras de
l'extrême gauche je me suis Mélenchon de
pousser les électeur à droite dans les
bras de Marine Le Pen pour en fait se
retrouver un peu à la tête d'un bloc
d'un bloc central le résultat c'est
effectivement cette fracturation
terrible dans le pays le fait
qu'aujourd'hui on se demande quel peut
être l'alternative donc nous nous
considérons que ce jeu de fracturation
il est mortifère pour notre pays et que
demain il doit rester une alternative
possible qu'il ne soit pas qui ne soit
pas le rassemblement national ou qui ne
soit pas l'extrême gauche
souhaitez pas que des républicains
rentrent au gouvernement
et on se finira pas ce qu'on promette et
je déconseille auprès de la République
de continuer ce petit jeu de débauchage
d'ailleurs il y a plus il y a plus grand
monde à débaucher d'ailleurs
mais que vous prêt à à faire pour
justement essayer d'avancer parce que je
le rappelle quand même les législatives
ont accouché d'un nouveau
parlementarisme finalement les Français
au bouton demander à vous les députés
les élus de deux c'est exactement ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
depuis six mois l'Assemblée nationale
elle prend et les députés au sein de
cette Assemblée prennent leur
responsabilités le gouvernement propose
des textes
des textes plus ou moins parfois sur
lesquels on arrive à construire des
majorités très larges on a voté cette
semaine un projet de loi de relance du
nucléaire il a été voté à plus de 400
voix une très large majorité il y a que
les écologistes et l'extrême gauche qui
conformément à leur conviction ont votée
contre ce texte mais il a été adopté
très largement il y a des sujets où
évidemment c'est plus compliqué
mais sur ce texte de retraite tu aurais
peut-être une une majorité non pas voulu
prendre le risque à l'extrême gauche
elle-même à empêcher qu'on vote
d'ailleurs je rappelle sur l'article 7
Olivier marlacio il y aurait vraiment eu
une majorité sur ce texte chez nous il y
avait une majorité de députés qui
étaient qui étaient prêts à voter il y
avait une bonne trentaine de députés qui
étaient prêts à voter effectivement si à
partir du moment où au sein de la
majorité elle-même il n'y avait pas le
plein voilà mais en tout cas ça montre
que certains Assemblée nationale je
pense qu'elle peut fonctionner et amener
et elle oblige effectivement le
gouvernement qui est désormais un peu
sous une vraie tutelle de l'Assemblée
nationale à ne pas faire n'importe quoi
Emmanuel Macron quand il parle d'une
nouvelle méthode un nouveau calendrier
législatif de rationaliser finalement le
travail parlementaire en découpant les
textes on trouve des textes plus courts
voir passer par la voie réglementaire ça
vous interpelle arrêtons de légiférer
sur tous et n'importe quoi ça je pense
qu'effectivement tout le monde tout le
monde en est d'accord j'en fais trop de
loi trop de loi qui ne servent à rien
dans ce dans ce pays donc si on peut
déjà arrêter si on peut arrêter de
d'utiliser la loi comme un outil de
communication politique le problème du
texte monsieur Darmanin par exemple
c'était d'abord ça c'est que c'est un
taf qui qui ne réglages sont de rien
avec le leur idée de titre de séjour
nouveau qui était en tension sur les
métiers en tension mais en réalité en
état du droit on peut on pourrait dans
les secteurs de crise dans des secteurs
on peine à recruter un préfet totalement
la possibilité de délivrer un titre de
séjour
on le fait par exemple dans les secteurs
de la de de la santé elle préfère savent
régler les choses les situations cas par
cas donc il y a absolument pas besoin de
cette de cette loi pour un pilotage soit
plus fin soit beaucoup plus ferme de de
l'immigration sur l'exécution des auqtf
on sait que oui elle a rapport de Front
national buffet qui propose d'améliorer
la procédure le contentieux etc mais on
sait que le problème c'est quoi c'est
juste un problème de diplomatique c'est
que la France est pas foutue malgré les
les milliards d'aide au développement
qu'on donne à des pays d'Afrique n'est
pas foutu en contrepartie d'exiger la
réadmission les laisser passer ce
consulat pour la rémission des étrangers
parle même pas du Parlement c'est juste
au gouvernement à l'exécutif de faire
son boulot qu'est-ce que vous répondez
au président quand tu justement il parle
de de saucissonner la loi Asie
l'immigration avoir une partie projet de
loi plus consensuelle et peut-être des
propositions de loi euh du consensuel en
matière de l'immigration j'ai déjà du
mal à y croire en même temps en matière
migratoire ça n'existe pas c'est plus
d'immigration ou c'est moins
d'immigration et là-dessus effectivement
c'est un peu le problème de ce texte
c'est à dire que l'aile gauche de la
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale je
rappelle que un grand nombre de députés
de la majorité viennent aujourd'hui du
Parti Social ce sont des anciens
socialistes
ne veut ne voulait pas voter un texte de
durcissement des règles quand alors que
Monsieur Darmanin prétendait faire le
contraire donc évidemment il y a un
moment l'illusion l'illusion s'évanouit
donc que le gouvernement utilise déjà
les outils une fois encore l'expulsion
d'un centre de personnes ça relève juste
de la volonté de la propriété parce que
là on va vers un texte qui va être
scindé une partie du socle une partie
Gérald Darmanin est-ce que vous voterez
à droite la partie Gérald Darmanin
c'est-à-dire sur
rien
ce texte c'est l'arlésienne ça fait ça
fait 6 mois qu'il est qu'il est reporté
là il a fait Pitt il a disparu donc
une fois encore ce qu'on fait un texte
de fermeté ce qu'on fait un texte pour
qui est moins d'immigration en France ou
est-ce qu'on fait un texte pour
faciliter les flux on peut pas faire les
deux en même temps c'est pas forcément
besoin justement
est-ce que vous dites il y a pas besoin
de texte voilà c'est ça en fait
il y a besoin d'un texte mais pas d'un
petit texte on a pas d'un petit texte
donc je je pense on va on va remettre
nous sur la table très rapidement avec
Eric Chiotti une proposition de loi sur
sur les questions sur les questions
migratoires on a mais on a on a déjà on
en a fait plusieurs on a toutes les
solutions on va redéposer un texte
on va leur mettre très rapidement des
choses sur sur la table juste pour
revenir à cette nouvelle méthode
législative que que veut Emmanuel Macron
est-ce que vous craignez une volonté de
contourner le Parlement
quand on est le Parlement je pense pas
je dessine une fois encore je dirais il
y a deux pouvoirs il y a un exécutif et
un initiatif que l'exécutif fasse déjà
fasse déjà sur son boulot arrête ce
cinéma législatif qui parfois est
totalement
inutile il y a des grands moments dans
la vie démocratique sur lesquels il est
obligé de venir dans le Parlement ce
sera le cas sur la loi de programmation
militaire ce sera le cas sur évidemment
le budget mais une fois encore il y a
beaucoup de politiques sur lesquels il y
a pas besoin de venir devant le devant
le Parlement donc qu'ils utilisent déjà
leurs outils et puis je pense qu'il faut
vraiment que le Président si il y a une
chose à faire c'est vraiment
qui ne comprennent qu'il a comprenne
qu'il admettent et qu'il accepte de
changer de stratégie par rapport à cette
fracturation du pays qu'il a créé
changer de stratégie ça veut dire quoi
Monsieur il a eu depuis 6 ans il n'a eu
de 16 de radicaliser de provoquer les
Français d'une fois encore cette
stratégie consiste à pousser les gens
vers les extrêmes aujourd'hui c'est
cette situation là elle n'est plus
tenable dans notre pays et donc je pense
vraiment qu'il faut que le président est
dans les jours qui viennent c'est tout
l'enjeu qui commence à apaiser donc ça
veut dire arrêter avec ce jeu ce jeu
extrêmement extrêmement pervers que
quand il proposait il y a quelques
quelques semaines le sujet toujours
d'actualité d'aller accueillir d'aller
installer des centres des centres
d'accueil de demandeurs d'asile dans les
dans le monde rural c'est quoi d'autre
sinon une provocation
donc il faut arrêter ce genre de
provocation arrêtez de radicaliser les
Français de de semer cette cette colère
imprégner ce qui va se passer dans les
manifestations aujourd'hui et les
prochains jours vous pensez que les
propos d'hier vont radicaliser les
manifestations
vous avez à la fois une extrême gauche
très radicale
avec des casseurs
c'est pas par qui sont contrôlés et puis
vous avez un mouvement social
traditionnel avec des gens tout à fait
normaux qui qui manifestent de manière
plus beaucoup plus pacifique
on aurait pu s'adresser au second
malheureusement une fois encore il ne
l'a il ne l'a pas fait c'est pas qu'on
puisse dire du coup que les syndicats
soient débordés par ces mots franchement
il y a ce risque que le mouvement
continue
et qu'on ait cette
histoire et soit polluée
par-ce que et quelle peut-être la
réponse de l'État on a entendu le garde
des sceaux Eric Dupond-Moretti appelé à
la fermeté les les procureurs est-ce que
c'est ça la réponse une
la plus grande fermeté face évidemment
face au casseurs face à la provocation
et puis je reste je reste vigilant sur
la façon dont les doctrines de maintien
de l'ordre moi j'avais été assez choqué
pendant la crise des gilets jaunes sur
la façon dont les choix qui étaient
faits par le préfet de police de
l'époque sur sur le bateau monsieur
l'allemand où on a le sentiment que
la stratégie choisie
favoriser le contact entre entre les
manifestants parfois les parfois des
manifestants violents et les forces de
l'ordre évidemment il faut l'éviter à
tout prix donc ça veut dire éviter des
provocations de la part des des casseurs
de des gens les plus violents mais ça
veut dire ne pas exposer les forces de
l'ordre et donc pour être l'impression
je suis très attentif non je connais pas
ça parcours professionnel je pense que
c'est un professionnel beaucoup plus
sérieux voilà mais c'est il y a de vrais
sujets donc cette stratégie de de
maintien de l'ordre des factions et des
factieux comme la Feuillère le chef de
l'État non j'aime pas les mots comme
quoi le président de de de la République
voilà une fois encore il y a des il y a
des gens
il y a des gens qui aujourd'hui polluent
polluent débat politique ont empêché
quand j'entends Monsieur Mélenchon
dénoncer dans ce recours aux 49-3 une
fois encore celui qui a aussi sa part de
responsabilité qui empêchait le
Parlement de débattre je la loi elle
aurait pu être elle aurait pu être voté
mais il y a un choix volontaire de la
part de l'extrême gauche que surtout ne
pas prendre le risque de faire en sorte
qu'il n'y ait pas de de saut
démocratique sur ce texte en réalité
donc il y a eu un vrai sabotage organisé
par par l'extrême gauche à l'Assemblée
nationale ils ont essayé de faire la
même chose au Sénat d'ailleurs
donc voilà les choses
enfin l'extrême gauche a sa part de
responsabilité aussi dans le climat
délétères que nous vivons on va revenir
à votre partie vous me disiez tout à
l'heure ne pas souhaiter de débauchage
individuel et ne pas souhaiter que des
républicains entre gouvernement mais il
y en a d'autres dans votre partie et pas
des moindres Rachida Dati notamment il y
a aussi Jean-François Copé qui eux prône
un accord de coalition avec Emmanuel
Macron qu'en pensez-vous avec avec
Chiotti avec l'immense majorité de
d'ailleurs de mon groupe à l'Assemblée
nationale on a répondu à cette question
depuis le depuis le début
j'avais trop de trop de choses nous nous
séparent nous sépare d'Emmanuel Macron
on a parlé de l'immigration depuis six
ans ça politique matière migratoire est
un fiasco absolu il y a aucune volonté
on est aux antipodes de ce que nous
pensons en matière de de justice de
réponse pénale la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron est aux antipodes de ce que nous
attendons aujourd'hui les problèmes
d'insécurité ne sont pas réglés pourquoi
parce qu'on n'a pas les réponses pénales
monsieur monsieur Macron et Monsieur
Dupont-Moretti ont gardé toutes les lois
de Madame Taubira regardez la question
des penchées ils ont refusé pendant des
années et jusqu'à quelques semaines
encore de de remettre des peines
plancher pour les récidivistes donc on a
on a de trop de choses trop de choses
nous nous séparent voilà mais après nous
assumons nos responsabilités quand des
textes arrivent et qu'il rejoignent ce
que sont nos convictions d'ailleurs on
n'est pas les seuls j'avais le
rassemblement national a voté le texte
sur le nucléaire par exemple le
rassemblement national a voté
l'orientation sur les moyens du
ministère de l'Intérieur donc voilà nous
avons parlé au cas par cas est-ce que
vous je me suis mis aussi votre
responsabilité sur la réforme des
retraites ce que je vais vous rappeler
la une phrase de direction dit l'échec
du gouvernement est ton premier lieu
celui du chef de l'État qui n'a pas su
convaincre les Français de la nécessité
de la nécessité d'une telle réforme mais
n'est-ce pas aussi le vôtre vous qui
n'avez pas su convaincre je dis vous
Olivier Marley c'est Éric Ciotti pas su
convaincre vos propres troupes de la
nécessité de la réforme et qui a mené
aussi aux 49-3
il y avait dans mon groupe effectivement
une vingtaine de députés ceux qui ont
voté la motion censure qui qui ne
souhaitait pas voter cette cette réforme
pour des raisons divers
je crois qu'il y a une conviction qu'on
partage quand même tous et c'est le plus
important de commencer par là
on est convaincu que ce pays ne se
redressera pas si demain on ne travaille
pas tous un peu plus
le drame de la France aujourd'hui je
pense que le ce qui explique toute la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
c'est l'appauvrissement de notre pays on
n'est plus que 25e au 25e rang en termes
de PIB par habitant c'est un
effondrement
du pays c'est un appauvrissement du pays
c'est un appauvrissement des Français
son produit moins de richesse ensemble
on a moins à répartir notre système de
solidarité aujourd'hui une repose plus
que sur que sur la dette notre notre
niveau de vie sociale en réalité il est
accrédit et donc il faut d'une manière
ou d'une autre travail puisqu'on ne peut
pas être le pays au monde qui travaille
le moins dans l'année et le moins
donc le président de la République un
problème c'est qu'au centre partie
monsieur Marleix c'est complètement on
ne sait plus quelle est la ligne qui est
celle-là donc c'est pour ça que je
commence par ça la ligne c'est celle là
alors effectivement certains après
le président de la République d'avoir un
texte amené trop brutalement on peut pas
leur donner tort ce texte sur les
retraites il est annoncé il annoncé quoi
début décembre et il est posé sur la
table début janvier est-ce que ça va
avoir des conséquences sur votre groupe
est-ce que vous allez gérer de la même
façon quand vous avez 19 députés
non ça n'aura pas de conséquence sur sur
notre unité parce que au fond on partage
cette idée cette responsabilité qu'on ne
peut pas raconter d'histoires aux
Français et qu'il faudra travailler un
mot important en effet on ne sait plus
ce que vous partagez au sein de des
républicains la séance du conseil
stratégique à montrer quand même les
fractures qui existent au sein du parti
hier des gens comme Aurélien Pradier qui
était la tête de pont du de l'opposition
à la réforme des retraites semble
complètement en roue libre et pas du
tout en capacité de jouer de jouer
collectif est-ce que c'est votre
sentiment c'est que finalement ces gens
là comme Aurélien Pradet comme d'autres
n'ont plus rien à faire dans le parti
non vous avez des gens qui ont eu encore
si tu es des motivations très
différentes vous avez des députés qui
n'ont pas voulu voter je connais deux
ils sont très attachés à la question de
de la famille et qui est qui vraiment ne
pouvait pas voter on aura même
conscience qui considérait que il y
avait pas de réponse sur sur la
politique sur l'enjeu essentiel qui est
finalement la question la question
démographique donc en fait de motivation
extrêmement différente et au final au
final on peut pas reprocher au député
d'opposition de ne pas avoir voulu cette
réforme qui a été rejeté y compris par
des députés de la majorité tellement
elle était malade et normalement elle
était pas mal sur la question d'Aurélien
Pradier qui est visiblement n'a pas
vocation à suivre la moindre directive
de la direction du parti il y a un
moment c'était lui faudra poser la
question de savoir effectivement ce qui
partage avec ce qui partage avec les
autres est-ce que est-ce que d'autres
personnalités dont on a certains disent
au sein de votre propre rencontre qui
qu'il joue une sorte de billard à 12
bandes je pense à Laurent Wauquiez ou
Xavier Bertrand est-ce que concrètement
ces gens-là ils ont aussi vous leur
demandez de de reprendre pied dans le
dans le parti de de redéfinir ensemble
une stratégie pas de je crois pas que de
bizarre il faut encore faut pas donner
d'interprétation
politicienne au fait que le députés ne
voulait pas suite à cette réforme je
prends le groupe le groupe a beaucoup
parlé à l'assemblée que le groupe liote
le groupe de de Charles Azay de Courson
quand même un vraisemblable et
extravagant que ce groupe qui l'a député
un groupe de députés plutôt modéré
ce soir radicalisé comme ça contre la
réforme de retraite ça montre que il y a
eu un défaut de fabrication dans la
réforme des retraites un défaut de de
méthode qui est essentiellement le
manque de dialogue social le manque de
de de de souplesse on a fabrication de
ce de ce texte on a réflexion et que
certains du coup n'y ont pas retrouvé
leur petit donc je rendais pour rien
c'est une radicalisation du groupe lot
on est pour rien si au sein du groupe
horizon le groupe de Monsieur Édouard
Philippe Le Vaillant Édouard Philippe
et donc Olivier Marley
cette espèce de ce refus du se rejet de
la méthode il a existé aussi dans mon
groupe et franchement je le comprends
est-ce que vous regrettez son silence
Laurent a fait le choix de s'extraire du
quotidien de de de de la vie politique
de pas être comment dans un tel moment
notre vie politique on a l'impression
que c'est une série une punchline tu
vois on ne peut pas on transformera pas
ce pays positivement on ne se
rassemblera pas avec une vie politique
qui n'est qu'une succession de punchline
sans conviction profonde et je pense que
pour reconstruire ce projet il est pas
il est pas inutile de prendre un tout
petit peu de recul merci Olivier merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité merci
Julien